en las calles de Sari en el norte de
Irán una mujer baila frente a una
hoguera antes de lanzar súbelo al fuego
un ejemplo que siguieron rápidamente
otras dos manifestantes
en Kerman en otra protesta por la muerte
de masamine una joven Se cortó el pelo
delante de la multitud mientras contaba
muerte al dictador ese mismo lema se
escuchó en masat y en todo el país en
medio de una creciente ola de protestas
contra el gobierno las manifestaciones
se extendieron a las universidades como
Aquí en Teherán donde los estudiantes se
enfrentaron a los agentes de seguridad
el martes hubo protestas también en
carach disparan pero también Más allá de
las fronteras de Irán Incluso en
Estambul y Toronto a mí murió el viernes
mientras estaba bajo custodia policial
tras ser detenida por violar el código
de vestimenta iraní para las mujeres la
ONU pide una investigación Imparcial
las acusaciones de tortura y malos
tratos deben ser investigadas con
prontitud para garantizar en particular
que su familia tenga acceso a la
justicia y a la verdad las autoridades
deben dejar de perseguir acosar Y
detener a las mujeres que pero respetan
las normas
las autoridades iraníes por su parte han
negado cualquier responsabilidad
publicando estas imágenes que aseguran
muestran a la mini desplomándose en una
sala de espera Teherán insiste en que
murió debido a un problema de salud
preexistente sin embargo su familia
niega cualquier enfermedad previa